now germany has joined the list of
countries reporting omicron as the
dominant coronavirus variant now
accounting for more than 70 percent of
all new cases that's according to the
country's disease prevention center the
robert [ __ ] institute with such a rapid
spread german health minister carl
lauterbach is urging those not yet
vaccinated to get their shots quickly
germany saw a record number of new covet
19 cases on friday with more than 92 000
infections experts say measures like
masks and distancing have helped to
contain the advance of omicron but more
might be required
let's get some more perspective on the
story we can speak to toby escort he is
an epidemiologist at the charite
hospital in berlin good to have you back
on the program
do you think this trend of new daily
record infection rates is likely to
continue in the coming days and weeks
yes i expect this to continue omicron as
you mentioned is very infectious and the
numbers are very high right now and i
expect this number to continue to rise
with incident rates probably uh over a
thousand
well when i ask you about the impact
that that might have because we keep
reading that
omicron is milder than uh previous
variants like delta for example does
that mean that the burden on hospitals
and on medical workers is easing or will
ease
unfortunately not so yes omicron has
milder symptoms but this is on average
which does not mean that people
are not getting severely sick and as
many people are still not vaccinated
there's a high chance that some of them
will unfortunately have to go to the
hospital and because of the high number
of cases that we see even though it's a
little bit milder and maybe you're not
having any symptoms but if you will get
symptoms and so for the healthcare
system this is still in a very alarming
situation so the aim for authorities now
is to try to slow this wave down do you
think that the measures in place here in
germany are sufficient to prevent the
surge that you're talking about
now certainly good so wearing mask
vaccination is is key keeping distance
is certainly key but this virus cannot
pretty much be stopped right now because
it's so infectious and nevertheless we
should try to continue to
reduce the number of contacts wearing
mask wherever possible for sure indoors
and and just trying to really um go
through this wave together in a very
respectful way wow this very cannot be
stopped right now that's pretty
remarkable to hear that i mean
why are some of the infection numbers
here in germany still lower than in
other european countries do you chalk
that up to um
you know the the masks in social
distancing here or other measures
nothing is difficult to say i don't
think that the numbers are um if you if
you're looking
across several weeks will will not be
that different than other surrounding
countries from from germany it certainly
started a bit a bit later we have seen
this also in the second wave but i don't
think there's a
a clear difference compared to other
countries
we'll have to leave it there tobias
court epidemiologist at the charite
hospital here in berlin thank you very
much
pleasure thanks for having me
well for more on this i'm joined now by
our political correspondent thomas
sparrow
thomas
we're seeing a record number of
infections here in germany driven by the
omicron variant of coronavirus how is
the country coping
it's in fact terry the third consecutive
day that germany registers
uh record in the number of infections
you mentioned already 90 000 over 90 000
new cases in the last 24 hours and that
trend is likely to continue the robert
koch institute the country's public
health institute has said that they
expect a strong increase in the number
of cases driven by the omicron variant
in the next few weeks and as you can
imagine this is a scenario that is
causing a lot of concern not only among
citizens in fact a new poll revealed
that a majority of germans are really
tired with the whole situation also
concerned about the whole situation but
also among authorities that are trying
to identify what the best measures could
be there have also been reports here in
germany about
labs and test centers being overwhelmed
not all labs and test centers are
overwhelmed in fact yesterday we were
reporting here in berlin and we went to
various uh testing centers but there are
concerns that if the numbers continue to
rise this could affect germany's overall
coronavirus strategy under such
officials are looking very carefully at
how these numbers develop in the next
few days and weeks
the german government thomas is pushing
for mandatory vaccination it's a highly
controversial
move
how likely is it that germany will
actually introduce a vaccine mandate
experts do say that it is highly likely
that that measure will be approved it's
important terry to stress that that is a
measure that will be decided ultimately
by mps here in the bundestags in the
german parliament not by the government
as such so it will be interesting to see
how that debate develops in the german
parliament if you judge the public mood
on this a majority of germans certainly
favor now mandatory vaccinations yet
it's interesting to also point out that
this is a change compared to the public
mood a few months ago if you looked at
the public mood a few months ago you
would have noticed that a majority of
germans were actually against mandatory
vaccinations the change has to do with
this very delicate situation and with
the fact that many people understand
that vaccinations are the way out of the
pandemic and that's also by the way the
reason why many in the german government
and also many mps favor now mandatory
vaccinations to deal with the
coronavirus pandemic
thomas thank you so much that was our
political correspondent thomas bera
well teachers in france have staged a
one-day strike over their frustration at
rules surrounding the kovit-19 pandemic
around half of all primary schools
remain closed on thursday as the omicron
virus variant fuels one of the biggest
infection rates in europe teachers in
france say they're facing an
unmanageable burden they're demanding
clearer rules and more protection in the
classroom dw correspondent christine
mundo reports from paris
tests have become part of daily life in
france
and testing facilities are struggling to
cope with the growing demand
as cases skyrocket across the country
it's a huge workload we have lots and
lots of people coming and many of them
test positive
400 people that i test there are at
least 150 positive cases so we can see
it's really coming back
many people are showing up at official
centers like this one to confirm
positive results of tests taken at home
i was tested positive by antigenic this
morning about two hours ago something
like that and i just want to be sure
that i'm positive because i have no
symptoms no things so that's why i
prefer to do a pcr test in case that my
antigenic was fake actually
i hope the first test i did was a false
positive because otherwise my class will
be in quarantine for a week and we won't
be able to go to school that would be no
fun
millions of children are not yet
vaccinated and schools in france have
been hit especially hard in this fifth
wave with class closures and staff
shortages as infections spread
on thursday teachers walked off the job
on mass over what they say is the
government's failure to adopt a coherent
policy for schools to manage the
pandemic
to face this health crisis we need
specific measures to be put in place air
filtering systems ventilation and
protocols that can actually be
implemented to keep us safe but nothing
is being done
much of the anger is being directed at
the education minister jean-michel
blanchet who provoked outrage by saying
you can't strike against a virus
as that virus rages the government is
planning to tighten covert pass rules to
further restrict access to public spaces
for those who choose not to be
vaccinated the delta variant is still
circulating within the french population
but
the real reason behind the sharp rise in
cases is really the omicron variant and
health experts here say it's going to
peak in the middle of january and that
that's going to be followed by an
increase in hospital admissions
the who says half of europe will be
infected with omicron within the next
six to eight weeks
authorities in france are hoping that
the 30 million booster doses already
administered here
will help ease the burden on the health
care system
here's a look at some of the latest
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
worldwide washington wants to double its
purchase of covet 19 rapid tests to 1
billion as the u.s struggles with the
omicron variant spain will cap the cost
of coveted self-testing antigen kits at
just under 3 euros the government has
come under increasing pressure over high
prices
poor countries turned down around 100
million donated covet-19 vaccine doses
last month the u.n says that was mainly
due to the vaccines nearing their
expiration dates
to india next where covet 19 infections
are on the rise the new wave is being
driven by the omicron variant with more
cases recorded on thursday than at any
other time in the last 236 days
now if you look back at the number of
cases over the last year we see the big
spike in may that caused so much trauma
then figures going gradually down and
remaining largely flat up until the end
of 2021 and now we see the curve edging
upwards again
now initial findings suggest people
recover faster from omicron than
previous variants but as dw's manira
chaudhary reports from delhi there are
concerns that hospitals could still be
overwhelmed
a new year a massive new wave in india
after months of low infection rates
ko with 19 case numbers have shot up
the third wave of the pandemic has the
country in its grip
the positivity rate in delhi of those
being tested is at 25 percent
experts say the actual figure in the
capital and the country is many times
higher than that
most scientists now agree that omicron
is driving this wave while many indians
are anxious about the increase others
say things may be easier this time
around third wave we have to be careful
the third wave is here i'm here at the
hospital with my mother who's a patient
we have to take extra care here because
it's quite crowded
i've been hearing that this time the
virus is spreading much faster than
before but i don't think it is as
dangerous because people are recovering
quickly at their homes
dr karthike kohli says the severity of
symptoms and rate of hospitalization may
be low with omicron
but people still need to be very
cautious
delta involved the lungs quite a lot
whereas in this one it is only related
to the upper respiratory tract hence the
symptoms are faster quicker and the
recovery is quite fast actually
but he warns that given the speed with
which the virus is spreading people are
still at risk
especially older people and those with
pre-existing conditions
studies suggest that the third wave will
peak sometime around january end to
february beginning and then we'll see a
sharp decline
even though this wave is expected to be
short-lived experts say that it still
has the potential to overwhelm
healthcare infrastructure once it hits
its peak
public health officials are worried that
the spread of a highly infectious
variant in a country of 1.3 billion
people could have serious consequences
if we let the virus have its way
possibly we'll see it
rise fast and then also decay fast maybe
in the next two to three weeks but it is
in our interest to stretch the wave so
that you do not simultaneously have a
large number of people falling ill
because that can be very disruptive
efforts are being made to avoid the
massive upheaval of the delta outbreak
indian authorities have implemented
weekend and night curfews to slow the
spread
people are hopeful this wave will be
shorter and they will be spared the
hardship so many went through less than
a year ago
and a doctor who's worked closely with
patients over the last year told us what
he saw as key for india to better manage
the expected omicron wave
i think the key this time around is
going to be how we manage
hospitalizations uh individuals need to
be encouraged as much as possible to
manage their illness at home knowing
that this is self-limited for most
individuals
india tends to be a country where a lot
of health care is paid for out of pocket
so there's sometimes a lot of pressure
to get hospitalized uh by patients even
when they don't really warrant
hospitalizations as long as we can
manage a lot of the illness at home and
reserve our beds only for the tiny
fraction which really needs to be
hospitalized
hopefully this time should be a lot
better than last time around